elon musk runs two incredible companies
tesla and spacex
but what if i told you that he doesn't
actually run spacex day-to-day
and i have the data to prove it the
flight logs from elon's private jet make
it clear that tesla is his number one
priority
but we'll dig into that later gwen
shotwell is the real head of spacex
and she's the only reason that spacex
keeps hitting all of these insane
milestones
but i'm not being an elon hater here
hiring a great operator to help you
execute a massive vision
is one of the best things that an
entrepreneur can do and gwen is
seriously the best operator in the
entire tech industry
but no one seems to talk about her i
have a bunch of theories as to why that
is
but let me show you exactly how gwen
runs spacex first
elon is known for setting really
ambitious goals but it's gwyn
that actually makes those dreams a
reality it's common for founders to hire
adult supervision when their companies
start to get really big
mark zuckerberg hired cheryl sandberg as
his chief operating officer in 2008
when facebook was just a few years old
gwen is chief operating officer of
spacex
but she's also the president of the
company and that extra title
is really meaningful the title of
president can mean a lot of different
things depending on the company but what
i'm about to show you will make it clear
that she's much more than a second in
command
spacex would be nowhere without her when
elon posts a crazy tweet suggesting that
a brand new spacex rocket might blow up
on the pad
it's gwen shotwell who flies all over
the world to assure
key business partners that the launch
will go according to plan
she's a steadying force in the company
but that doesn't mean that she isn't 100
aligned with elon's ambitions
she wants to create a mars colony just
as much as elon does
but unlike elon she has a financially
viable plan to actually get it done
i love analyzing leaders like gwen on
this channel because there are so many
key lessons that can be applied to any
startup
i'm an entrepreneur myself and learning
about success stories like hers always
inspires me to work harder and dream
bigger i put out videos like
this weekly so please consider
subscribing not much has been written
about gwen shotwell so i really had to
dig through
interviews and podcasts to figure out
what allowed her to scale spacex so
effectively
the space industry is highly regulated
extremely capital intensive
and just downright hard it is literally
rocket science after all but i think
i've nailed down how gwen thinks about
business
so let me summarize it in three separate
parts first up is her background
before she became president of spacex
gwyn spent decades becoming an expert in
the relevant skill sets needed to
succeed in the aerospace industry there
are great startup ideas that don't
require highly technical knowledge
just look at all the social networks
founded in dorm rooms by college
dropouts that are now worth billions
but rocketry is a little different now
gwen didn't know that she wanted to work
in the aerospace industry as a kid
she's actually said that she never
dreamed of being an astronaut
which is kind of crazy since i thought
everyone had that dream as a kid but she
did have a fascination with engineering
and leaned into it at a young age
i don't think i was nerdy but i was
definitely doing the things that the
girls
weren't doing i asked my mom who was an
artist when i was in third grade how a
car worked so she had no idea
so she gave me a book and i read it and
sure enough my first job
out of my mechanical engineering degree
was with chrysler motors in the
automotive industry
this is one of the best things about
technical disciplines not many people
are willing just to crack open a book
and start learning but if you can buckle
down
and learn the science you'll have an
incredible advantage over the
competition but elon musk didn't trust
gwen to run spacex just because she was
a talented engineer by the time gwen
joined spacex
she had worked in the aerospace industry
for over a decade
and i can't stress enough how important
this is
many people tend to think of themselves
as their job title
a typical engineer might bounce around
from an advertising company
to a bank and then to a car company and
that can be a great career
but if you want to become a leader like
gwen it's much better to focus on
developing a breadth of skills that are
relevant to your specific
industry instead of getting stuck in a
particular division of spacex when she
joined gwyn was able to wear
many hats because she had so much
aerospace experience
she came in as head of business
development which is essentially a sales
role
but because she understood the industry
inside and out
elon kept tapping her for bigger and
bigger projects
it can be uncomfortable to take on new
roles at a growing company but gwen
understands that building a diverse
skill set
is key to successful leadership and
you'll never build new skills if you
don't take risks
when i was considering joining spacex
back in 2002 i was struggling with the
decision and drawing it out for weeks
it seemed so risky for me personally to
join this little startup in an industry
where none had ever succeeded at the
time i was a part-time single mother
and this was just too far out of my
comfort zone i was driving on the
freeway here in la when it finally hit
me i was being a total idiot
who cares if i tried this job and either
i failed or the company failed
what i recognized at that moment was
that it was the trying part that was the
most
important try that risky thing be a part
of something exciting
when opportunity knocks you need to open
the door joining a startup as employee
number seven was extremely risky for
gwen but by taking a big leap of faith
she put herself in the perfect position
to expand her skill set
and become a true leader in the
aerospace industry but all her ambition
and experience would be nothing without
execution
this was nearly 20 years ago after all
and spacex had a long road ahead of it
becoming a successful rocket company
would require an entirely new way of
thinking about the business
and fortunately for spacex gwynn had
discovered something incredible
if you've never heard the term residual
capability before
that's completely fine it's definitely
pretty jargony
residual capability just means building
profitable business lines around
technology that you already have
in order to support your longer term
projects and this is gwyn's second key
success factor
she's a master of capitalizing on
spacex's residual capability there are a
few great examples of residual
capability really changing the game for
spacex
the first is starling their satellite
internet network
spacex didn't set out to create an
internet service provider their stated
mission is to make human life
multi-planetary after all
in fact elon probably hadn't thought
about providing internet service from
space at
all when he started spacex the internet
is cool and all but it doesn't have much
to do with getting to mars
at least that's what everyone thought
before gwynne created spacex's financial
plan
getting to mars wasn't going to be cheap
the rocket required to take a crew of
people on the months-long journey
will be absolutely massive so gwen
started breaking elon's vision down into
small steps that could ultimately lead
to a mars colony we've all seen spacex
launch satellites for other companies
but along the way gwen realized that by
launching their own satellites
they could create a sustainable business
here on earth and help build technology
that will be needed for mars
see the cost of each incremental spacex
launch is decreasing over time
every time they launch another rocket
they are learning important lessons and
becoming a more efficient company
launching a network of satellites into
orbit for starlink would cost billions
of dollars
but once they were up there they would
generate profits for decades to come
additionally a future mars colony will
need a communications network of their
own
and all that experience setting up
satellite networks here on earth
will translate pretty directly into a
mars satellite network and gwynne was
the perfect person to lead the starlink
effort at spacex
because she had championed a deal with
iridium back in 2010.
spacex had great relationships with
government customers
but doing business with independent
corporations would be important too
so gwen signed a 492 million dollar
contract to launch
75 iridium satellites into orbit using
falcon 9 rockets
gwen figured out how to bring in extra
business for spacex back in 2010 and
that experience allowed her to leverage
that residual capability
to start an entirely new business line
with starlink in 2015
but that's not the only time that gwynne
has championed this idea of residual
capability at spacex in fact the entire
design philosophy of spacex's big falcon
rocket
is based on the idea of residual
capability it's exactly this residual
capability so we developed the merlin
engine for the falcon 1 launch vehicle
we could have tossed that engine and
built an entirely new engine for the
falcon 9 it would have been called
something different obviously because
falcon 9 is nine merlin engines but
instead of spending a billion dollars on
a brand new engine
we put nine of them together on the back
end of falcon 9. residual capability
blew three falcon 9s together and you
have the largest operational rocket
flying and that's not all spacex is
planning to offer point-to-point travel
on earth to allow people to get from new
york to shanghai
in just 30 minutes developing this
business from scratch would be nearly
impossible
but because gwynn had successfully
executed on so many other spacex
projects
they now have a real shot of making this
a reality although it probably won't
happen for years
gwen has been asked directly about when
this point-to-point capability would be
widely available
within a decade for sure this is win
time or elon time
that's win time i'm sure elon will want
us to go faster this response tells you
everything you need to know about why
gwyn has been so successful at spacex
elon is notorious for being overly
optimistic about timelines
and gwen acknowledges that all while
still maintaining ambitious goals
too many people hear elon announce an
aggressive timeline
and instantly write him off because it
seems impossible gwyn understands that
elon's timelines might be overly
ambitious
but he's still directionally correct
about where the technology is going in
the future and she's a hundred percent
on board with his vision
it's common knowledge that elon can be a
demanding boss but gwen has been working
alongside elon for nearly 20 years now
and she wouldn't stick around if they
didn't see eye to eye on the future
and this is gwyn's third key
characteristic that makes her such a
great leader at spacex
she loves absurd goals set and try to
achieve
absolutely absurd goals and don't be
afraid of failing
if you can't achieve them this idea of
setting absurd goals
is extremely powerful mostly because of
human psychology
see this relates to something called
parkinson's law which is the old adage
that work expands to fill the time
allotted to put it simply the amount of
work required to complete a given task
typically scales to the time available
for its completion
so if the spacex team said something
like getting to mars will be really hard
and will probably take
50 years they would almost certainly
spend 50 years on the project but the
downside risk of setting an absurd goal
is actually very minimal
sure people might make fun of you but
none of that matters
just keep building towards that goal and
you will eventually achieve great things
elon is known to set particularly absurd
goals
and gwen is typically a bit more
realistic in her estimations
she has to keep the company alive after
all but the key thing to note here
is that she is still a hundred percent
aligned with elon
on the gold she has the same ability as
elon to think long term and imagine
what's possible for humanity over
decades instead of just years she's made
plenty of money at this point
but i think what keeps her really going
is a desire to improve the life of
future generations
she already has children and has said
that she wants grandchildren
so even if spacex can't accomplish every
single goal within her lifetime
i think she'll be remembered for
hundreds of years as someone who helped
change the course of humanity forever
and that's incredibly powerful if you
want to go a layer deeper
just enter your email on johncoogan.com
and please check out this recommended
video
the youtube algorithm thinks that you'll
really like it